>> Bret: THANK YOU, WE WILL
SEE YOU LATER IN SHOW.
THIS IS ANOTHER FOX NEWS ALERT,
ONE OF THE ADVISORS WHO HAS BEEN
WITH DONALD TRUMP SINCE LONG
BEFORE HE BECAME PRESIDENT WAS
AWAKENED THIS MORNING BY FBI
AGENTS IN A SALT GEAR SHOUTING
AT HIM TO OPEN HIS DOOR.
TONIGHT, ROGER STONE IS FACING A
SEVEN COUNT INDICTMENT CHARGING
HIM WITH VARIOUS CRIMES LINKED
TO THE RELEASE OF HACKED
DEMOCRATIC PARTY EMAILS.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS TO
SPECIFICS.
>> ROGER STONE WILL BE ARRAIGNED
ON TUESDAY IN A D.C. FEDERAL
COURT.
HE WAS RELEASED ON A $250,000
BOND.
LEAVING FEDERAL COURT IN
FLORIDA, A DEFIANT ROGER STONE
WAVED A PEACE SIGN LIKE HIS OLD
BOSS RICHARD NIXON AS BOOS AND
CHEERS RANG OUT.
THE LONGTIME POLITICAL
OPERATIVES AND FRIEND OF
DONALD TRUMP SAID THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL INDICTMENT IS BASELESS
AND POLITICALLY MOTIVATED.
>> THERE IS NO CIRCUMSTANCE
WHATSOEVER UNDER WHICH I WILL
BEAR FALSE WITNESS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, NOR WILL I MAKE UP
LIES TO EASE THE PRESSURE ON
MYSELF.
>> SIX HOURS EARLIER, HEAVILY
ARMED FBI AGENTS RAIDED HIS
FORT LAUDERDALE HOME AT THE SAME
TIME THE SPECIAL COUNSEL SERVED
HIM A 24 PAGE SEVEN COUNT
INDICTMENT INCLUDING FALSE
STATEMENTS, WITNESS TAMPERING,
AND OBSTRUCTING AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> THE SPECIAL COUNSEL OFFICE
RELEASED A PRESS RELEASE PRIOR
TO INFORMING ME I WOULD BE
CHARGED TODAY.
>> THE SEVEN COUNTS GO TO THE
HEART OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
ALLEGATIONS THAT A SENIOR
OFFICIAL WOULD BE UNNAMED.
A SENIOR CAMPAIGN OFFICIAL WAS
DIRECTED TO CONTACT HIM ABOUT
ANY ADDITIONAL RELEASES AND
OTHER DAMAGING INFORMATION
ORGANIZATION ONE -- WHICH IS
WIKILEAKS -- REGARDING THE
CAMPAIGN.
POTENTIAL FUTURE RELEASES OF
DAMAGING FUTURE MATERIAL.
THE INDICTMENT DOES NOT ACCUSE
HIM OF CONSPIRING WITH WIKILEAKS
OR RUSSIAN AGENTS, INSTEAD OF IT
ACCUSES HIM OF LYING TO CONGRESS
ABOUT HIS WIKILEAKS CONTACTS.
>> TO DO IT ANYWAY WORK WITH THE
RUSSIANS TO HELP PRESIDENT TRUM
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> CATEGORICALLY NOT.
>> THE PRESIDENT WE DID QUITE A
SWITCH IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY, NO COLLUSION, HIS
ATTORNEY SAID THE INDICTMENT
TODAY IS YET AGAIN NOTHING MORE
THAN ANOTHER FALSE STATEMENT
CHARGE, IT DOESN'T ALLEGE
COLLUSION.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE ARE COMING TO
AN END BACK.
WITH STONE CHARGED CHARGE TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL HAS EITHER
INDICTED, CONVICTED, OR GOTTEN
GUILTY PLEAS FOR OVER 30 PEOPLE
OR BUSINESSES.
ATTORNEY MICHAEL COHEN, CAMPAIGN
CHAIRMAN PAUL MANAFORT STONES
FORMER BUSINESS PARTNER.
>> THIS CONNECTION TO THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTION IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO GET TO THE
TRUTH ABOUT.
>> 20 MONTH INTO THE INDICTMENT
NONE OF THE PUBLICLY PROSECUTED
CASES HAVE ALLEGED COORDINATION